today we are checking out the nothing
phone this is such an interesting device
and i've been so excited to see it in
person and i'm so excited it's here
let's unbox it look at this box it's
also incredibly unique like it's so flat
like this to me looks like something
that you would get like a chocolate bar
in like this doesn't look like something
that a phone or some sort of device is
in but a surprise
it is so there's a little arrow right
here which i assume we're gonna just
pull it
let's see what's inside
oh looks like we have
some
instructions love those i'll definitely
read those later
and we also have a sim card ejector but
the sim card ejector looks like a pill
like this would be something that you
see in the matrix he's like do you want
the red pill the blue pill or do you
want the nothing phone sim card ejector
pill this would probably stab your
insides if you swallowed it so i
wouldn't recommend that but this is a
super unique sim card ejector
so i have seen videos of this i've seen
photos i've seen a ton of content but
now
i'm getting to see it in person
so all of the reviewers have said pretty
much the same thing that videos and
photos do not do this justice because
when you're actually looking at this in
person like there's depth that you can
actually see like you can see inside of
this thing it's really really really
really cool it's crazy because this
looks like an iphone like if someone
said to me and i didn't know any better
and it wasn't actually in tech and i
just was like on the street walking
going for a walk and someone said hey
what phone is this i'd be like um maybe
an iphone it has a very iphone-ish look
especially with this dual camera the
front-facing camera is over here on the
left-hand side and this does already
come with a little screen protector
which is very nice now the specs of this
phone are pretty good but they're
definitely not the highest end flagship
specs that you would expect to see in
something like this but this phone is
really pushing the boundaries as far as
design is concerned because they did a
lot of really unique things in this to
kind of make up for the fact that it
isn't the highest and top of the line
device so i guess now the only thing to
do
is turn it on
yup yup it is here we go the nothing
phone has dual sided gorilla glass
giving you a view of this unique back of
the phone that they are calling the
glyph interface there are around 900 led
lights that have different patterns to
indicate different types of
notifications charging progress and you
can even use it as a camera fill light
it's made with 100 recycled aluminum and
with over 50 percent of the plastic
components coming from bio-based and
recycled sources the phone is running
nothing os that ensures no bloatware
just a smooth experience with clean
design widgets font sounds and
wallpapers there's a red led on the back
that will blink when you're recording
video so no recording surprises there's
also no headphone jack but it does have
an under display fingerprint sensor a
4500 milliamp hour battery fast charging
50 in 30 minutes and 100 in 70 minutes
it also does have wireless and reverse
wireless charging so you can charge a
friend's phone if theirs happens to be
dead it is a 6.55 inch oled 120 hertz
adaptive refresh rate display running
snapdragon 778 g plus 5g eight gigs of
ram 128 gigs of storage it comes in
black and white it also has an nft
tracker to show them off in five
different sizes and you can even track
their prices on your home screen with
their native nft gallery i'm pretty
hyped about that not gonna lie and also
it won't even be available in the u.s so
yeah i'm sorry so we're connecting to
wi-fi it's getting my phone ready i
already like the way that nothing
integrates their font styles like it is
a very unique look and i think that's
pretty cool
oh my goodness
what
this is so cool
oh wow okay so that's my default
ringtone
what the heck is that
you're doing stuff
so not only
are the lights going but like there's
also haptic feedback happening so with
each sound on each pulse of the light
like my phone i can feel it
this one's called tennis
the sounds are so good
okay this is way cooler than i thought i
was gonna be like who knew that i needed
to have a phone with lights on the back
that lights up and does
weird stuff here we go video
recording light indicator oh there it is
there it is look at that that's official
oh my goodness this is cool definitely a
nice feature let's take a photo
oh i like the sounds they're so cute
[Music]
jake this is you hello say hi
move super wide
let's see how close we can get on macro
it's pretty close so to use the back
glyph lights as a fill there's a little
flash right up here so you can click
that just to turn on the auto flash
which is there and then this is the
glyph fill light so you can see right up
there it says glyph fill lights and then
on the back
check that out so here we are oh this
looks really cool like this is honestly
something like if you took this outside
and showed people right now they would
be like
oh is that the future and i would say
yes
this is the future i'm holding it in my
hand now we're recording with the fill
lights and with our recording light on
so
this is pretty awesome i'm very into
this there's no sneaking around filming
with this just saying that this looks
like an iphone yeah of course but when
you put them up next to each other like
look at this i mean it's a great design
so yeah i freaking get it do you see
what i see but the real question is can
your iphone
do this
all right we're testing out the
front-facing video now this only does
shoot in 1080p so you're obviously not
gonna be getting 4k quality from the
front-facing camera but it still is nice
to have i'm not sure where to look
because
here i'm looking i'm supposed to look
there that's where the lens is it's in
the bottom left whereas the iphone it's
usually like right here in the middle
oh i've almost run into a succulent well
thank you guys for watching hope you
guys enjoyed this quick look at the
nothing phone i'm so excited that i got
a chance to check this out like i've
been dying to open up that box and see
what this phone looks like in person
it's definitely way cooler than i
thought and this design has by far
exceeded my expectations like the photos
and videos they really don't do it
justice it looks incredible if you guys
are new here i'm justine i cover a ton
of tech stuff phones drones cameras
computers you name it it's probably here
if you guys haven't already be sure to
subscribe hit the bell to be notified
when i post new videos and of course
leave me some comments below i would
love to hear what you guys think of this
device i'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]